ce qui nous frappe malgré tout dans des
personnages on en reparlera tout au long
de ses trente cinq minutes c'est ce côté
anti star que tu as et c'est voulu
je sais pas ouais je sais que tu n'as tu
n'aime pas qu'on dise du bien de toi
pourquoi c'est le cirage de pompes ce
qu'on ne fera pas alors ici toutes
grandes stars vous êtes numéro vous êtes
formidable moteur parce que tu sais pas
quoi répondre s'ils trouvaient en plus
ça veut pas dire grand chose et si
c'était la vérité parce que malgré tout
il ya quand même des choses qui qui qui
trouble j'ai noté quelques si par
exemple on dit que les disques sont en
crise et que depuis 78 les albums ont
chuté de 42% alors que toi tu vas tu vas
tu donnes tu t'arrêtes pas de vin dans
chat 45 devient disque d'or chaque album
devient un disque de platine
c'est quand même important et ça
représente quelque chose tu veux pas
dire c'est à moi oui non mais ça je suis
d'accord ça ça fait plaisir que les
chansons que je fais plaisent aux gens
mais je crois au contraire que
éventuellement ce qui peut plaire c'est
justement ce côté pas strass différents
et c'est peut-être que les gens se sont
attachés aux chansons parce qu'elle leur
semblait pas ce que je leur ressemble et
que je suis pas différent peut-être ce
recul que tu parles d'un rapport amitié
ça corresponde véritablement de
tempérament je ne peux pas dire que ce
qui représente le métier avec des
guillemets c'est surtout tout ce qui est
cocktail réception boîte de nuit et tout
ça je peux pas dire soit des endroits
qui m'excite beaucoup mais enfin même
quand je faisais pas ce métier c'était
pas un endroit beaucoup par contre si le
métier c est dans des studios être sur
scène être avec des musiciens ça c'est
un métier que je fréquente beaucoup et
avec beaucoup de plaisir
est-ce qu'on peut te baptisé star
marginal nantel j'avais entendu un yves
montand on lui disait vous êtes une star
il a dit star ça veut dire étoile en
anglais ouais et donc ça c'est quelque
chose qui est loin des gens
donc je suis pas une star et alors moi
je me sens bien comme ça parce que j'ai
vécu 30 ans dans dans l'anonymat
et j'étais très heureux d'y être et je
fréquente et des gens qui me plaisait
beaucoup et j'ai pas du tout l'intention
que ça change
[Musique]